hey little
i'm talking to you directly
i'm coming on tour and i don't always do
it so you got to come see me and here we
go april 15th and 16th i will be in
louisville and evansville april 23rd and
24th i will be in tulsa and oklahoma
city beacon theater new york city first
time may 14th there's going to be some
surprise guests there and that's all i
could say but you do not want to miss
that and i'm going out west cali i'm
finally coming to you i'm going to be in
san diego on may 21st and at the wilton
theater in los angeles for the first
time ever on may 22nd everything is
available right now at
savolcanocomedy.com you little bit
this friday march 25th the win las vegas
baby we're going to be there tt jerry's
coming on stage april 8th the egyptian
room at the old national center in
indianapolis indiana april 9th denver
colorado april 16th wall street theater
norwalk connecticut april 29th wind
creek event center in pennsylvania
christy comedy.com for all the tiki
wikis thank you guys we'll see you at
the
[Music]
be afraid show be ashamed don't hesitate
to say hey babe hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe there goes my hey babe
watch him as he goes down
now
there goes my
baby
you guys never considered losing that
it seems like you put a lot of pressure
on yourselves like everything normally
we have like they just used to come yeah
but i wasn't thinking of it today so i
got you guys yeah yeah we had a little
bit of a scramble to find the song
before this started a little bit of
showing them behind the curtain yeah the
sausage getting made yeah yeah yeah uh
gremlins three is inevitable if hbo max
succeeds this is basically a part two i
didn't even change my shirt oh you
normally yeah i don't normally change
because i like i just don't want them to
look at the thumbnail and think they saw
it on one right right yeah so yeah i'll
change a chain this is a nice little
technique we'll do for the for you
focusing my hat off for this one i will
change to like uh
hair looks good to me what do you think
so yeah that's good what's that baby his
hair i think it looks good
fantastic
i do i have so last uh last episode we
polled people to see how many people are
shoes off household or keep the shoes on
households and the results are in
what do you guys think
uh i think off
upon thinking about it like i do take my
shoes off the second i get in the house
but it's for comfort i just don't ask
guests to take it off i guess
i guess i should have asked that do you
have guests removed i just put is your
home a shoes off situation or no worries
keep shoes on i bet your shoes off on
9000 votes oh
pretty close closer than i thought 57
shoes off yeah but it's that's
43 shoes on so this it's like pretty
much
50 50 nearly yeah
i think it depends on where you live
city or not city
true okay
so if i lived in like a rural area
dragging that cow [ __ ] through your
through your house i just don't see how
anyone does shoes on because then you're
you're walking
you constantly got to clean the floors
constantly but don't you clean the
floors anyway yeah but like when i'm
just walking around with cotton socks
no i don't worry about that but i have
robots i have the roombas uh i love
those things and they work oh i got my
mama room but she vacuums and then i go
what are you vacuuming for you have the
roomba and she goes i do it as a base
she doesn't need to so that the roomba
doesn't so like that i help the roomba
to run the room
so so now before you had the roomba you
vacuumed and now you have the roomba and
you're vacuuming so what are you doing
yeah yeah that's i think that's like a
like an older like person adjusting to
from what what i use right yeah is the
dyson animal or whatever oh it's like
the v10
well it's a little older maybe it's a v8
i don't know okay but like that that
seems like it's doing way more damage
than the roomba the roomba feels like
it's like this little thing that's not
powerful yeah it's not a deep clean type
thing but it is it you'll be surprised
dude like the cat hair is [ __ ] gone
and this is happening while you're home
while i'm home i just set it to a timer
or if i just want it or i just hit a
button does it make noise
yeah but it's not so you're home and
you're hearing it you pick it up and go
from room to room uh i have done that
but at this point i have three i have
three roombas so
did you hit them all at the same time i
haven't done that i could try the
jetsons in your house i put googly eyes
on them all did you really name them
yeah oh that makes it a lot like i'll
walk in the kitchen and i'll be like
morning ted ted's the kitchen one no
yeah and then and then i just hit the
button and ted cleans and i'm like all
right i go go get him ted oh the googly
eyes is hysterical yeah yeah all of them
you ever race them uh no because they
they really go in weird direct like they
don't just come out if roomba's out
there and i know you're listening ah
if you're listening to rumor we know
that you are yeah like it's it's um it's
i don't understand the pattern it
doesn't just go it's like all over the
[ __ ] map but they claim it's it's
better for it
really yeah it just feels like it's like
i don't know what to clean first i think
it's like because it knocks dirt like it
has a spinning brush and it knocks dirt
out to like loosen it and i think it's
all to just get that loose dirt so okay
gotcha yeah and
but how much could it hold like my
canister on the on the dyson it's like a
it's like a like a huge like self self
emptying baby
it's got it it's got a base with it with
a bat with a vacuum bag in it and it
crawls up on the base and then you have
it sucks all the dirt out of the room
and then like once a month you just get
rid of that bag oh
so what happens if the roomba itself
gets full it'll go
empty it and then start again yeah but
that doesn't really happen but yeah
that's what it would do well it's not
for carpets nothing carpets really yeah
so you have a room but dedicated to your
kitchen the kitchen's not that
well when you have cats that cat hair is
especially in the kitchen
you don't want any build up in there so
ted ted runs about three to three times
a day in the kitchen oh and you set that
or you have to hit it every time yeah
it's it's an app
oh it's an app but you could also
program it so it just yeah you could
time it you could use it let me ask you
this does it learn the dimensions of the
room yes it does
so then and it still goes in
any which way even though it knows where
it's supposed to go yeah it knows it's
it's like you're saying i it's when it
goes to human eyes
it looks like it's going to every which
way between a robot
it's yeah
if you picked up ted and you dropped him
in the in the den would ted be like what
the [ __ ] is going on he'll map that [ __ ]
in one run oh he said he won't he won't
think he's in the kitchen and then like
slam it to the desk and be like ah my
[ __ ] no he does he does a lot of
banging see so it's like
so the the irobot app and that's ted
say and i could hit that here and he'll
just start cleaning no he'll start
cleaning now yeah right now
get going ted so you could even empty
bin if you if you're worried that he's
got too much
and is it ever like not now ted
uh not really
no not really
ted i'm on the phone
no i have gotten out of like like
because what it will do is he'll just go
about his business and and i'll feel
guilty because if he knocks into you he
spins and goes in another direction okay
so i'll worry that i'm interrupting
ted's work
so i'll get out so i'll get out of here
like you're like he's like sorry me lord
sorry yeah yeah yeah and it's just great
and it was like it's it's perfect it
gets rid of that like because i have a
cleaning lady and i and i'm always like
so nervous when she shows up because i'm
like just i just want to be nice to her
and these people become like you know
part of the family after a while like i
see her once every two weeks
so now how does she look at the robot i
don't think she's even like
cared about that robot because she gets
paid no matter what it probably loves it
i don't think she thinks she's getting
replaced by the robot
i don't know i think we're a few years
away from them walking have you seen the
fdny bought robots now oh the yeah the
the those are freaky that's a great idea
they remind me
is it like in my head
if i'm remembering right because it's
been a long time since i read it but
fahrenheit 451
yeah is that what's called ray bradbury
455 451
good luck spelling fahrenheit pimp 451
right
yeah all right fahrenheit 451 451 yeah
didn't they have like motorized
dogs like robot dogs in it that attacked
remember i thought they did i never held
this book up to the same
uh
like level of of of worship that most
people seem to i tried to read it and i
was like it's just kind of boring yeah i
i remember liking it
i thought it was kind of dull but you've
read a million books and i've read maybe
30 yeah maybe uh but it's crazy that
people are protesting the dogs going
into fires instead of people wait people
don't like that idea there's like a
whole community of people saying that
it's not right and that the dogs are
actually being used to mine our data
from our homes when it's on fire
hey [ __ ]
they're like
you mean the robot the robot has sensors
and stuff and they're saying [ __ ] do you
think's gonna be left to your house if
there's a fire that they're sending a
dog in like that's crazy
uh those things okay i'll tell you right
now these creep me out that creeps you
out yeah that creeps me out well you
know what that is
yeah but it's it's something about it is
creepy to me
like it it's not it's on something about
is unsettling to me i i understand what
you mean but it but i could see i would
be helpful you know in a fire the dogs
yeah i guess dog both of both the dog's
legs bend that way right in real life
yeah like it's just like you never
notice it as much yeah they just it just
seems
weird
it does i see what you mean but i love
it i i think it's because it almost
seems like it already has a mind of its
own so it seems imposing but i would
have this thing clean my house yeah
would you have like a full real robot
dude the second that i can i get one of
those i'll get one of those my problem
is this is it's not gonna be
3po and r2d like this is what we've
learned like those people complaining
about the dog are actually right in a
lot of ways because it's like
yeah here's the guy complaining like if
it's going to be r2d2
it's it's not going to be r2 it's going
to be your robot pal it's going to be
connected to amazon and it's going to
like you're not gonna trust it so i
don't have like an alexa in my house and
[ __ ] like that i just don't trust it so
yeah the dream's dead it'll be all apps
and [ __ ] imagine you find out the
roombas are just mic'd up
i did some research i did some research
on that um but what are you gonna do
yeah my i need a clean kitchen so oh i
got something on the roomba but so
you're saying a place could be a blaze
yeah and the robot dog could just run in
yeah they'll probably set it into like
high high dangers and what does what
does it do sweep the area and say the
structure's about to fall this is how
hot it is the size on the inside yeah
yeah it's a great idea you can find
people bodies like imagine you see that
dog
oh well i think someone controlling it
from remote two different modes i think
i would assume so you can but that
thing's not going to save anybody no but
it could but yeah of course well it's
not going to pull anybody out all right
but it'll locate it i mean it's so hard
to see and if you're not even going and
like just like set off like a like a
like almost like a water bomb yeah
oh good yeah you could put foam on it
for sure
why you could put like fire suppressing
foam on it grenade yeah
i wonder if it's do it nypd robot dog
hits streets what's that gonna do that's
just gonna get hit by a car stolen i
don't think that that's well that's
their issue the people who are saying
the fdny shouldn't hire him is because
then the nypd will and they'll send it
out to just collect your face on the
street i don't know your face is already
collected could you imagine if those
things are not tended to like they are
free roaming
at one point
like you know you're not gonna be
walking next to a cop the whole point
right at one point where those are like
automated and they roam the streets and
it's like or when they stand up
guarding this like why when they stand
up straight this is the first model yo
did you see it stand up straight no it
stands out
i seen one of those stand up straight
before
and it it it was also very unsettling
i'm surprised police went for something
ground level like that you think a drone
would be good for them
this i've seen the the bigger model i've
seen oh that maybe that's what i was
talking about yeah
oh that's kind of like yeah that's scary
dude it's such full transformer
that's pretty nuts and it can carry like
hundreds of pounds
i think it's great oh that is that is
that is
is that real yeah
the the fluidity of the movement is
unbelievable who's better than i do
how do you even dude that is very scary
but what scares you about that i like i
don't look at that and think of that as
scary i'm like wow when can they put a
vagina into it
i'm like what's going on i'm just like
i'm just wondering like in my head i'm
going to like the most sci-fi place like
if that becomes sentient oh yeah well by
the time that happens we'll be so old
i'd be so hyped to see that thing clean
my house yeah god
that that'd be great for security
you could just have a wandering the
neighborhood yeah like just patrolling
your grounds they have or like if
someone breaks in they can just run to
the door and just dominate them that's
so scary
seeing it in nature walking in the woods
in the snow
oh man no but that i i i mean i'm sure
the price point is not going to be
consumer level but like imagine one day
where it's just like oh we just have a a
we have a security robot that's going to
happen without a doubt in our lifetime
my thing is like this it's just like
these
yeah i mean these robots
to some degree will have to be
self-automated
and if not intelligent at least
artificial intelligence type thing right
like one day this robot let's say you
bought this robot for your family right
and it lived with you the day's gonna
come where it's gonna become obsolete
so there's gonna be junkyards full of
these
old robots that serve no purpose anymore
and like are they going to be able to
think are they going to be aware of
their situation
there's got to be a power down scenario
is that [ __ ] cool
i mean you have rosie the [ __ ] maid
for 10 years and you're like well all
right well there's a new model we're
going to shut her down and just [ __ ]
chip her out wow that is
like that's what i worry about because i
worry about that with ted i'm like yeah
and that's not even that that's not
doesn't have any intelligence and but
i've bonded with it because i put the
[ __ ] googly eyes on it and i named it
and like one day ted's gonna go and i'm
sure i'll just toss him out but this
sort of thing living in your house being
part of your family and then you're just
like oh there's a new model let's get
right to watch this what he just did he
just knocked it out of his hand and
pushed him
no he shoved him back and the robot went
like flying back
and then came forward again this one
oh and you're you're fearing the day the
robot's not going to take that [ __ ]
they're always like yo what was that
about yeah
that'd be great i i hope they play jazz
when they all get obsolete oh it's going
to be weird man
think about that like there's going to
be a whole second market for robots
and like if a robot god forbid we come
to the era where robots actually have
some sort of self-intelligence and
feelings and [ __ ] but they're still
these [ __ ] they're considered objects
that is going to be a nightmare for
these robots i feel really bad about it
yeah and i bet you they'll oh my god
yeah we'll see how it plays out but they
might make the robots live in certain
areas look at that i don't even like
that he did that to the robot yeah like
suddenly you're like
from behind like okay it's just weird
because it looks like us but like you're
saying that at one point when they
achieve certain amount of whatever but
then they're looked at as just robots
they're going to have an issue with that
if you cover that in skin like good skin
did you see ex machina yeah
that was crazy give me that robot yeah
but also but also don't yeah but all
right yeah i also don't want to be
locked in a room to start yeah i love
that i saw that movie two times in the
theater but think about where you
remember that galaxy note that you had
whoever where's that thing today
now imagine it had developed a bag in
the closet right like you're gonna have
a closet with three robots that are 20
years old in there yeah and you're gonna
open the door and they're gonna be like
sal
hello sal do you need a burrito and
you're gonna be like sorry i closed the
door it's like it's not gonna be great
we did a sketch one time where we
based on your roomba wasn't it your
roomba yeah it was my that was i still
have that roomba
yeah that that was the original ted
where brian's uh i guess grandmother
grandmother was you know in the sketch
was in a urn was there
her ashes were nerd and it fell
and shattered and then the roomba you
know activated and sucked it up and then
the roomba took the soul of his
grandmother
and then like from that point forward
his grandmother was in the room but so
whenever we'd go over it would always
come over like brian your friends are
over don't leave my mouth like that like
and then we started like she would talk
to her and stuff like that i forget like
i didn't like her i was like oh my
grandmother was a [ __ ] and like she was
just like nagging me the whole time yeah
yeah like you were happy that you didn't
have your grandmother would now she came
to life
yeah i don't know man yeah i think
robots
they pose an interesting problem oh 100
pounds
guys it's hard to believe but spring is
almost here and we're almost back to
getting that soft grass under our feet
but you need your lawn back if you're
not i live in an apartment but you need
the lawn back if you live in a house
thankfully sunday gets your lawn growing
and helps to keep it healthy all season
long you're worried about the chemicals
you're using in your yard you're worried
about your yard looking its best
traditional lawn care lays down 90
million pounds of pesticides each year
that's a lot of pounds that's like 90
million sunday is different they're on a
mission to change how people care for
their yards okay most of us might not
think about our lawns in the winter but
it's the time to prep right now is the
time to prep okay
sunday takes all the work out for you
they can help you grow a beautiful lawn
without the guesswork or the nasty
chemicals they have custom plans include
fertilizer and everything you need to
easily care for your lawn with
ingredients like seaweed iron and
molasses you can feel good with the kids
and the pets being around all you have
to do is visit getsunday.com put in your
address and their lawn analysis tool
does the rest then use the so they'll
use the soil and climate data that's
this is high-tech stuff to create a
personal nutrient plan delivered to your
door when you need it and then what you
do is you attach this pouch
to your garden hose or your sprayer and
you just go right through that and it
takes like less than 15 minutes it
really does work sunday's offering our
list is 20 off full season plans start
at just 129
and you can get 20 off at checkout when
you visit get sunday dot com slash hey
babe 20. that's 20 off your custom plan
getsunday.com hey babe 2-0
dot
at
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy guys let's talk better
help relationship takes work
relationships take work we always work
on our relationships with other people
but we don't often turn inward not as
much as we should be you know we're
willing to drop anything for people we
care about but we don't care about
ourselves self-help is the new black
not orange
all right i go to therapy uh everyone i
know does actually and it's it makes a
world of difference this month better
help online therapy wants to remind you
to take care of your most important
relationship yourself whether it's
hitting the gym making time for your
haircut or even trying therapy you are
your greatest asset so invest the time
and effort into yourself like you do for
other people better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to you can
start speaking to them in under 48 hours
they're licensed it's more affordable in
person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist like i said in under 48
hours give it a try see why over 2
million people have used better help
online therapy this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp and hey babe listeners get
10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
hey babe that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash hey babe also another like
futuristic problem which is that people
are now cloning their former pets
that's not a problem that's something
i'm thinking about but they're actually
mad at the pet for being different
well that's the stupidity i mean that's
just stupid so then what do you what are
they aiming for uh with the clone at the
pet is completely different
well looks the same i guess it looks the
same i don't know i i it doesn't make a
lot of sense but it looks the same oh
it's it's exactly the same it's it's
just but i know that you know your cat
and if you had another black cat next to
your black cat let's say at the height
of its life so it's it's less
discernible physically what it looked
like like you know what i mean like it
right when it was five years old whether
that's whatever 10 years like if you put
a black cat next to that cat or 10 black
cats
like is there a chance you might not
cite on site know which black cat was
your black guy for sure so then why
would someone pay 25 000 to just have
another well i think it's like a
grieving thing it's like uh but then
it's not like the cat well
you just is there something some solace
to knowing i think that's the genes of
the other cat every time i think about
cloning benjamin i think about it a lot
as he gets older i'm like because i got
him when he was eight and i was like i
never got to see what he looked like as
a kitten or so i'm always like oh that'd
be fun but at the end of the day like
it's it's an emotional thing it's
there's no logic to it understood
because that's like 50 first dates like
you're with someone who doesn't know
yeah the cat wouldn't know you have
history no it doesn't but you know
i agree it's a hard overhead thing for
sure
but i kind of want to do it but it is a
totally new cat so how do they do it
they take they take um
the way they clone the sheep the same
thing they take the dna they put it into
a cat's egg you know and like and then
put it into a mother cat and then it's
just born it's the same same process oh
all right yeah so then you're still
getting different dna from the mother no
no no it's it's not it's like uh it's
like um how you could pay someone to
carry a child you know like oh sorry
sorry it's the same thing it's it's all
the dna comes from the from the egg
that's already yeah but the mother's
donating the egg in a surrogate isn't
she
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it's
like all the dna is is put into it okay
so the half that would come from the
mother and the father is a replacement
and this is on a consumer level like you
can go to you can go to like something
local and get this done this is saying
25 the last i heard it was 30 so maybe
it's maybe it's a little cheaper now now
what do you what's more weird to you
doing this or getting cat like
taxidermied
i want to do the taxidermy that's that's
ghoulish to me
i never thought of taxidermy for like a
pet yeah i've thought about it and
there's this company uh there's this guy
i i spend too much time on benjamin
there's um this company that will
mummify them like the egyptians used to
do
and you send them the cat's corpse and
they mummify it what do you mean
they will like it yeah they'll wrap it
they'll do the whole thing they'll
they'll preserve it they'll wrap it like
the mummy cats used to be you don't look
at it
but then then they put it inside of a
statue of your cat so it's like a statue
of your cat with the insides the mummy
insides of your cat interesting yeah i
it doesn't work for me either but yeah
that's
people are doing also what else do you
have planned for benjamin really i just
circle around the clone thing more and
more because i would love to like just
have have that i think it'd be fun to do
especially if you have the money i i'd
do it because it's funny it's funny and
it's just like we live in an era where i
could do it why wouldn't i do it and and
poll's going up what's your take on
taxidermy in general
no problem with it or no way
we had a we had a person i don't wanna i
don't wanna say whether it's male or
female so i don't want this person to be
publicly shamed we the person that
worked on our show
yeah who did taxidermy yeah and it was
and this person would give out like baby
ducks and top hats yeah yeah and
waistcoats and [ __ ] to people and it was
it was a person that worked on the crew
and that show pretty cool yeah
i don't know man
it is it's definitely eccentric but when
you meet the person you're like so you
spend your time this is a long this is
this is like season one two well you're
like you cut open like you're cool
hanging out with like just slicing open
a dead baby duck and like stuffing it
she used to taxidermy though yeah i
don't know what kind of skill set that
is but like i had a guy i went to
college with and
he his family was hunters and he had a
big house somewhere here or whatever the
hell it was we went to his house for a
party one time we went in the basement
huge basement when i tell you right now
the basement had i'm telling you
it had no less than
50 taxidermy things in it but massive he
had big game cats taxidermy in his house
he had a huge
leopard
on top of a deer that it demolished like
so the deer was on the floor like that
but dead but taxidermied and the tiger
was like out on top of the deer he had a
grizzly
he had a goddamn bear someone you know
yeah oh i knew
that's weird i think bear is illegal i
feel like but there was a [ __ ] bear
oh my god i mean you could probably i
don't know if it's illegal you could go
bear hunting so you could oh well there
was a goddamn bear standing up yeah in
his like it was like not like when you
see like oh there's a deer on the wall
yeah or like or that's the only one i
could really accept is the deer on the
wall yeah but i don't really it's really
weird in theory i kind of think it's
kind of cool like the deer on the wall
but then
i don't know i don't know if i could
like like
i don't know i i don't know like you
just
first of all you can't just throw it up
anywhere like it wouldn't match in my
living room right now
i knew i might you know but like you got
to like have the like the kind of the
aesthetic for it i think yeah but like i
don't know how i would feel like when i
go into a store like there's a taxidermy
store on uh
spring street i think
it's like pretty well known uh and um
and i i i walk by and i always look in
and i'm like they look so cool like in
in the
company of other others yeah or in like
a study or a library or or in the
company of other taxes i'm always like
wow look at all this stuff but i don't
know if i'd how i'd feel if one was on
my wall in the home
uh i would buy one used
maybe like to put on the wall i wouldn't
want to kill yeah you don't feel it but
there's this thing in ireland i i
couldn't get you guys to go with me um
we were we were in there for tour one
time and uh there's this thing called
the dead zoo and i remember having a
conversation with you and we're about to
have it again and i was like we gotta go
see the dead zoo in dublin and i
couldn't get any of you guys to go with
me and oh my god this is wild it is just
it is just
a warehouse of taxidermy animals but
they have like extinct animals like i
saw i saw a dodo
and they're all over 100 years old again
they're bringing the dodo back now
scientists found dna frozen that thought
i guess in the icebergs really and
they're now bringing i'm all for it
bring it back no
now i'm like are we gonna have a new
lunch meat
oh bring it back
they keep promising they're gonna do
with the woolly mammoth and i'm like
bring it the [ __ ] back bring it back
what is that gonna do with the ecosystem
yeah i don't know we're the responsible
for them being like we're the ones that
[ __ ] like any yeah but i don't know what
it's gonna come back right now in this
world
well let's just put them back where they
were
i mean how long has the woolly mammoth
been gone
dodo bird is it just gonna stop flying
around with the other birds where's his
natural habitat yeah they're on like
these islands right yeah like you can't
just like don't you have to inject them
back to where they can survive yeah like
there's not gonna be a dodo bird it's
not gonna like just fly into my window
no they would have to go back to where
they 4 000 years ago they disappeared
right and but humans were responsible
for that right it says scientists if i
finally proved why
maybe it's in there as i understand that
did not humans did not cause wooly
mammoths
maybe we should click on that click on
that
what you the one right there woolly
madness did not cause can you make that
a little bigger yeah yeah
humans did not cause wooly mammoths to
go extinct climate change did for five
million years wooly mammoths roamed the
earth until they vanished for good
nearly four thousand years ago
scientists have proved why the hairy
cousins of today's elephants lived
alongside early humans and were a
regular staple of their diet their
skeletons were used to build shelters
harpoons were carved from their giant
tusks artwork featuring them is dobbed
dobbed on cave walls and 30 000 years
ago the oldest known musical instrument
a flute was made out of a mammoth bomb
how cool is that i mean there's some
information for you
the first the oldest known musical
instrument is a flute
made of woolly mammoth bone
well imagine roaming around for five
million years and then four thousand
years ago you're like oh it's over it's
over wrap it up guys what is that
happening to us
there'll be a time where they're like oh
they're human these were humans they
were they roamed but who's saying it
robes oh [ __ ] robots aliens
that that would be i'd be totally that's
the dodo bird i can see why it's called
that they're so delicious
that's why they went extinct right they
were so delicious no
people just [ __ ] ate them to death
yeah people would have like dodo bird
sandwich yeah like dodo bird eggs
all that [ __ ]
oh what a it looks so dumb
is that why it's called dodo though i
don't know because
people call like
over harvesting this is what we're doing
to the ocean right now conspiracy
dodo i thought was uh
synonymous with like dopey
maybe i mean i agree with you that's
what i remember when i was little my mom
used to like call people dodo birds
we'd be driving someone couldn't do this
don't oh kind of forgotten look at this
dodo bird
nowadays it means stupid or slow but how
did this extinct animal get a strange
name it may go back to early at 17th
century developed from the portuguese
word
dow do
or simpleton
probably because the bird had no fear of
a man and was easily killed oh my god
that we just walk oh so like they they
didn't have any like any fear mechanism
in them to like like you just walk up to
it snap it's like the one right next to
it still staring at you
it also doesn't look appealing at all
but it's cool they're kind of small like
this i'm saying you go to this place in
dublin they have actual ones
laid out for you and you're like holy
[ __ ] that's what a dodo looked like
bring it all back
yeah i don't know
i think i would get i would wonder if
you
if they could make your pet like your
dog look
happy and healthy and attacks the
dermated state
no i i don't know i mean i don't know i
i i'm too close to benjamin to want him
stuffed to see his his without his life
force and his animus taken from him i i
don't think i want to see that
but he's there he's there always still
his body is there yeah but it's cold
it's yeah it's not purring it's
yeah
i don't i don't know i kind of love him
the way he is alive i guess
um i had i was thinking about something
the other day
i was thinking about comedy oh and and i
didn't know that i was doing this until
last night so i didn't mean to bring it
up but i did want to ask you about it
in general just to swerve in a direction
yeah but
the fart right
funny yeah
and then i was like
wow the fart's always been funny which
means like for sure
king arthur
like i was just thinking like the one
thing but it's got to be to the
beginning it's like
the first part the first it was the
first fart think about that right
and animal farts and everything and it's
just like i i took some solace the other
night i was high for this i took some
solace the other night because i was
like wow like the one thing that
connected me to genghis khan that
connects me to every every human that
has ever lived of note
is without a doubt they farted in front
of their friends and they all laughed
about it
you think genghis khan farted in front
of his name i think he did it in front
of [ __ ] everybody he did it right
before he killed somebody before he
[ __ ] people before he did anything
like like name a historical figure and
it's just like there's no way they
didn't like find fart jokes funny
jesus jesus a hundred percent he hung
around with 12 dudes all day right they
were [ __ ] ripping farts left and
right it's universal yeah it connects us
all
yeah right think about that what else
does that
well i guess all human function no but i
mean humor i mean i mean you were human
in humor yeah that is kind of wild isn't
that crazy like also like when was the
first time it was left at immediate had
to be why because it's funny yeah but
you have to have like a little bit more
of your [ __ ] together up here to
understand oh you don't think that's a
caveman was like and the other was
i don't know oh i think so yeah do you
think there's people who can't fart
let's find out i hope not
it seems it can't let's say how many
times do people fart in a day
i think like 11 to 12 times a day is the
average that a person does that that
seems like a lot
no
one said five to 15 times a day wow
doctors say the average person
5 to 15
normal part of digestion reflects
activity of bacteria in the gut you
might also notice you're kidding
yourself if hitler didn't do fart jokes
like everybody's done it right
it's the crazy it's the craziest [ __ ] it
connects us all in a way
comedically that like is pretty nuts i
think oh that's like i couldn't get my
head around it yeah that was such a high
thought that's so funny yeah but like it
stuck with me as i came down like king
arthur farted
and laughed i mean it's [ __ ] nuts
dude i would buy this if it was a book
it's just every page is somebody else
who fought you already own it
damn it since it's been inside of you
all along
this joke
you know what i mean that's why
so it's not so it's not this is
impossible not to fart no it's not it
says it's not it everyone farts it says
everyone farts porn stars fart
porn stars porn stars fart of course
astronauts have farted on the moon oh
wow that's a good one like you're
telling me those astronauts and that
[ __ ] title capsule someone didn't rip
one and they all [ __ ] joked about it
like oh god buzz what the [ __ ] did you
eat this account says 10 to 20 times a
day oh god buzz
that's definitely farted up there it's
just so funny what are the surprising
facts you would never know
99 of the gas you produce does not smell
no that's very nice wow
whoa
farting is the result of a healthy
complex ecosystem in your intestines so
i kind of get that
there's a simple reason why you don't
mind the smell of your home what is the
simple reason
also who does everyone doesn't mind
that's what it means
that's like a thing a biological thing i
don't know i mean have you ever been
grossed out by your own
sure
gross down
yeah just like anything else you haven't
been like oh that's a winner like
well i mean depending on what how you
feeling that day but i'm sure it's like
jesus christ two now can it just be like
that too what was the most embarrassing
part of your life oh my god
oh man
i wish i would i wish i would be able to
call that up immediately i don't know it
feels like you should know right pimp
what would you do if you had no debt you
have debt yeah yeah some debt what would
you do if you had none wouldn't be the
best feeling in the world yeah you got
any high interest loans pimpy working on
it
you weren't bringing them down and
getting them we'll see well let's talk
upstart babes with upstart you can pay
off your existing debt quickly and
easily and start living your life if
you're carrying a credit card balance
month after month it can feel like
you're never you're in a never-ending
cycle of debt we've all been there with
no end in sight upstart can help you
make that final payment so you can get
ahead look you dread looking at your
statements you're not alone the weight
of the debt can be crippling we all know
it upstart is your path to financial
freedom it's a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with personal loan and
it's all online okay pay off credit
cards consolidate high interest debt
fund personal expenses okay over over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at a
credit store alone upstart considers
other factors like your income your
current employment and credit history to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate without
impacting your credit score in minutes
for loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars what's that what's a
thousand dollars a band
i think it's called a band right so from
one to fifty bands players you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting the loan so find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com hey babe that's
ups.com
hey babe don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application that's
upstart.com hey babe
coinbase babes
coinbase if you're crypto curious
coinbase is for you chrissy d uses
coinbase uh i'm gonna get into uh some
crypto and i'm a little curious myself i
really am and if you've ever thought
about entering the world or if you know
what you're doing but if you feel a
little overwhelmed coinbase makes
learning uh to buy and sell simple uh
you know like i said it might feel like
some crazy thing that other people are
doing but coinbase's theory is that
everyone everywhere should be able to
get in the door here whether you've been
trading for years or you're just
starting uh coinbase offers a trusted
and easy to use platform to buy sell and
spend your cryptocurrency they support
the most popular digital currencies on
the market and they make them all
accessible to everyone they offer
portfolio management protection learning
resources and a mobile app actually so
you can trade securely and monitor all
your crypto all the time all in one
place millions of people in over 100
countries trust coinbase with their
digital assets so for a limited time new
users can get ten dollars in free
bitcoin when you sign up today at
coinbase.com hey babe so sign up at
coinbase.com hey babe for ten dollars in
free bitcoin the offer is for a limited
time only so be sure to sign up today
that's coinbase.com hey babe
i farted on set once uh
and you looked at me like you're getting
old do you remember this no we were like
we were laughing we were like behind the
camera
and it was like [ __ ] oh like one of
the script girls were like right there
too and i was laughing and i was like
we looked at each other we just didn't
laugh and you're like you're getting old
and then there was like you know she was
like 22 i don't even remember what she
was she was like 22 and i was like i am
getting old i'm just far in her face
wait wasn't that like who who [ __ ] their
pants on stage one time is it murray
and it was like we were on stage and
we're like oh my god
he doesn't
i think the time he does right yeah and
then we'll be on stage and i'll be like
oh god and you don't want to call
attention to it and then but then one
time we did right here we go to the
sides but oh yeah
we stopped the show we're like i'm sorry
this is too much
this is too much we can't do it anymore
my buddy uh my buddy greg one time we
were flying home i think it was from
like
i want to say
it was either greece or like mexico or
something and he fought it basically he
sounded like he [ __ ] his pants it was so
bad and it was so it stayed so long it
was so when i'm telling you i'm not
going to be able to do it justice what
this
smell like and how long it stayed but
this is the result of it the
uh flight attendants decided not to come
back to where we were anymore and it was
it was after they served food and they
did not come collect our trays for food
can you believe that
they didn't come collecting trees
this is 20 something years ago abandoned
their duties they were 20 to 20
something years ago but we landed with
our trays oh my god oh my god that is
terrible yeah
we were like 10 of us more maybe even we
were crying and then he was like beat
red but like we we said it was him but
like
oh my god it was it was so bad though
like it was inescapable and it was
everyone everyone knew he did it it was
mortifying family i i went i like when
people fart on planes like i just say
say it
because we'll never identify who it is
so i'll just be like jesus
stuff like that like i'll do that it's
like just someone knows it's definitely
they know it's them and they know i'm
talking directly to them it happened to
me in covetings i flew somewhere with a
mask
and uh it came through the mess and i
said i go i go geez that went through
the mask
and it could be the person in front of
me behind it but like [ __ ] them but have
you ever used your fart as a weapon
no i like to do it in the gym when it's
all bodybuilders it just cropped us the
box are you serious it's so funny oh
that's just
i never thought
[Laughter]
i love it that's so funny
that's what you're thinking why do you
need to spite them they're annoying
they're screaming they're throwing the
hundred pound weights
you just pass by and [ __ ] yourself
yeah wow actually the gym is probably a
hotbed because all those protein bars
and stuff
shakes oh yeah plus you're constantly
changing your body position so it forces
chemicals and whatever those
supplements and [ __ ] i don't know could
be yeah i don't know we've never really
tracked in fart humor us
as a group really
in the show i mean how much can you do
anything well i think what i'm i'm
saying although i'm not arguing that we
start doing it it's just like i think
there's more to farts than we maybe we
just dismissed it
yeah we kind of try to like lop off
things that are just like
not go to the well too but we probably
did it more in the past
then we probably were like oh let's like
guys it can't just be no no no remember
we had a whole talk with everybody
i didn't
i did because i was like guys it's way
too much toileting in these in this
screen well too much soil humor isn't
good yeah i was like i would go down and
be like look like yeah if it's sex or
[ __ ] all right like and then i would go
down and be like guys make this ten
percent of whatever you're sending me
tops tops because like you don't realize
it's easy to write one of those jokes so
it's easy to put and then all of a
sudden everyone's thinking that way and
then they send us all this stuff and i'm
going through it and like it's half of
it i'm like guys this is crazy
so i think we put i think that's why
maybe we don't taste it maybe yeah but i
don't think at the same time i don't
think that was the wrong
right right
so there's got to be a balance just to
go to farts again one second has your
father my dad used to torture me with
lighting his farts on fire never seen it
in my life okay no i know it was just a
me thing that no you seen it i would
tell him to stop because it would make
me anxious that i was gonna shoot back
up how the hell do you do that he would
just
lay on the floor and have a lighter no
way you would see it yeah and he would
just like a little pot little yeah yeah
yeah he loved doing it because he knew
what made me anxious no [ __ ]
but your dad would just lay on the floor
in the house whenever it calls you'd be
like check this out check this out and
be like no and they have a lighter on
them you have a lighter [ __ ]
cigarettes he was in between cigarettes
oh my god
no i know no all right just me then no
is it there's gotta be i bet you there's
a video online of someone doing that and
going up in flames oh there's got to be
a fart fail
oh man that might we might have just
opened up a whole new genre
i sit at home when i'm home at night i
watch all sorts of fail videos all the
time i love it and i and i'll there's
like subsections of
cringe and talking about this yeah and
there's all these but sometimes they'll
find a new one and uh
you can see it
is that real that's got to be fake it's
got to be fake yeah that can't be real
that looks like axe body spray have you
ever done that trick
all the kids in high school put on their
hair and then light their hair and it
only burns it tips your hair off
no i've seen people's hair light up on
far we in bartending school remember
that girl's hair caught fire and when we
did the um
she was like super cute and like we did
a bartending thing one night oh yeah and
she leaned too close to the camel
yeah it was like two seconds and then i
think you and i were on it yeah yeah
yeah
it smells so bad that burning here yeah
wait what happens with axe body spray
like all the kids in high school was
like six months where everyone did this
in front of school where they spray axe
all over their hair and then just light
a lighter and all just catch and then go
out
i mean that's [ __ ] dangerous
like what if it didn't
it never it never didn't why would it go
out
i guess it would need more of the
aerosol
your hair would burn why doesn't your
hair burn yeah but the the the
temperature for hair to burn is way
hotter than the temperature for axe body
spray to burn so it just lights up the
axe body spray singes the air oh my god
it's insane yeah people used to use it
as like a flamethrower too like people
would like yeah axe body spray is
dangerous i've done it with old school
hairspray you like bloating like that
guy right now yeah
oh yeah fire and axe body spray yeah
yeah
that's that's dangerous dude i don't
know man i it seems dangerous to me do
you have you noticed
with this is kind of related to this but
like we're wrestling how much blood
there is in now in it yeah do you like
that or not like it um
i like it in moderation i don't mind and
i don't mind it if it's like not crazy
but when it's a red face that's all
they're doing it's hard to watch yeah
yeah i guess i'm getting old because i'm
starting to appreciate it well vince cut
that out but now he's been letting it
sneak back in a little bit i think but
aw is all over that aw i think an aw is
[ __ ] great but it's like i think it
takes that [ __ ] too far i'm like the
blood after a while i'm like i don't
want to see it anymore are they really
cutting themselves like what happened
yeah you see how you played splurt like
you like him punk out sometimes
yeah he did that was over the top
yeah yeah it was pretty nice i guess
they know what i mean by the time he was
done that he was just red yeah like i
mean i mean like carrie
what a tough job
yeah yeah the bumps they have to take
like they they hurt it's not like they
don't hurt i wouldn't even want to do
that
no oh yeah nah she she's actually
another one brit baker is another one
that's getting bloody like every other
is she really she just took a [ __ ]
thumbtack oh yeah the other night yeah
and i'm like holy [ __ ] sh you wanted
us to take thumbtack bumps on the show i
don't know yeah so what are you talking
about i was like no way because well now
you do you feel any like
jericho was on the show we had a whole
bunch of things we ended up doing
nothing like that with them but one of
the things was like to
be slammed on or just taking
on thumbtacks yeah they do it in
wrestling but it's like it's crazy they
get up and there's like 30 attacks stuck
in them and they all go in i mean it's
like
i don't want to have to get like tetanus
shots and stuff like that i don't know i
don't know how hard it could go how high
it goes i mean look at that
it's so crazy
maybe it
seems worse than it is i don't think
it's pleasant i think wrestlers have
this thing of just like look this job's
not about being comfortable it's about
yeah [ __ ] taking these hits and stuff
like that i i think i would take a
thumbtack hit
ugh because
one i'm getting too old so it's gotta
happen sooner it's gonna happen i mean i
don't wanna do it we're gonna be 50 soon
like i don't want to well not soon
four years flies pretty fast i don't
know but uh i don't know i'm like i'm
not there yet if we're gonna take a
thumbtack bump that's like the time to
do it is is now wait what does that
sentence even mean if we're gonna take
one i don't wanna take one ever yeah but
our show is based on doing things you
don't wanna do yeah but that's more
jackassy
no
just to being thrown onto thumbtacks
it's like this part of jackass would
just do it for its own sake like on our
show it would be part of a tapestry of
misery one part of it like the bit the
bit the punishment that i that i
proposed the other day that that i did
get shot down was we were on a bull ride
we were doing bull riding and there was
[ __ ] that you have to fall into
and i it was really just for thumbtacks
that i'd come up with it but then it was
like nothing matched thumbtacks really
to fall into so it kind of you know died
what do you fall wrong
one goes like where it's not supposed to
go
i mean they do it very measured they
like go back down into them right
i don't know they're body slamming each
other on to it it doesn't look like easy
what's that one well he is is that
someone pouring thumb tacks on people
even that would hurt
that's such a perfect stream of
thumbtacks 50 000 thumbtacks
when did they first start doing this is
such a specific oh this has been a long
thumbtacks for like the office
yeah i don't know how they find them in
the middle of the ring but uh
[Music]
but that's the goes office depot right
before the match and uh and then all of
a sudden the wrestler has thumb tacks on
him yeah
speaking of the lighting of the hair and
that crazy fads like that
what were pete kids doing with the tide
pods recently like was it because you
get high like what was the challenge
just eat it and don't die
what [ __ ] what [ __ ]
like what was it even the point of it
and what more and stupid enough to do it
chewing and gagging on pods and daring
others to is the same they were just
trying to get views on youtube by by
doing it and then the president
addressed it so everyone started doing
it so it wasn't really a thing it was it
was like like a problem it was a thing
for like the kids who you know you know
the kids from the neighborhood who were
so desperate for attention yeah
but they were like they were going to
get in trouble no matter what but what
was the point was just because they were
gagging
or was it like they were getting high i
think they got clicks on youtube by
doing it
so that's it yeah it was like the water
bucket challenge except no charity
nothing about it was nothing about the
tide pod no there was nothing there oh
okay and then todd had to address it so
everyone thought it was funny
it's hard how to address it would they
say don't eat detergent these are
[ __ ] funny that they have would they
tweet that yeah they made a statement i
forget what it was
i wonder if they lost business because
of that
if it was promotion
how many people do you think like in an
average day that you that you meet in
general and then how many
of those people not pandemic
pre-pandemic are idiots like how many
idiots do you run into in a day or
people you're like this is a [ __ ] so
many so many yeah think about it we the
odds are that we passed we just did we
just looked this up we passed the serial
killer sociopathic sociopath one another
they said one in a hundred working with
the sociopath yeah
we're talking about
they said one in a hundred people are a
sociopath one in a hundred i mean is
there any hope for [ __ ] society and
humanity is as a whole if you think
about that statistic
but then what did i did didn't i say
something and it was like i was a
sociopath oh because you know what
happened to me we talked about this on
two pods ago on when joe derosa covered
you're not associated
no but
we um so just so happens i swear tell me
if you agree or not agree i think it's a
message from from powers that be
i got delivered
another erroneous package of women's
pants
this this started when we did the what
say you this is more like what hey you
come on this is what hey you right now
what happened
um we started and this happened to me
during that and i told him for the first
time on that pod okay speaking of pods
on that podcast and
he knows the story because i told him
anyway uh like a week ago
i went to my other spot
and there was a bag there that had been
there for two months because you saw the
date of january on it and it was rained
on and the sun so the label was gone
and i was like oh what is this and then
i'm like well there's no name on it
it's yours
so there was there was a piece of the
address so i know like kind of where
it's supposed to go but not exactly so i
was like let me open it up
i didn't know it was pants yet obviously
let me open up see if this slips in
there with a name so i can get it back
to the giant i open it up it's red
leather women's like maroon
leather leather it's not a real leather
right it was like uh i don't know i
haven't done this i'll show you it look
it's very kind of like real leather very
fashionable
and they were a million people and they
were pants and i was like oh my god this
is the second time my life i got sent
women's pants by accident
and so i was telling derosa the story
and i told him i'm gonna this is the
continuation of the bit yeah let's see
what happens here he went nuts he said
that i'm insane and i'm gonna get
arrested or in trouble for doing it
because he said i wasn't supposed to
open those pants
and then because and he's like and he's
like you're going to send someone a rant
and then we looked up if you send
someone a ransom note in any way it
could be like five years in prison
so he's like you open the you open the
thing that wasn't yours you're going to
send the ransom note if they take it the
wrong way because the first girl
immediately talked about the fbi
but he was dead serious he's like he
wasn't making even a joke he was like i
don't do this this is ridiculous you're
stupid you're going to get in trouble
all this stuff and i was like really
i know you don't think he's taking a
little far
he thinks i'm taking it far i'm like joe
look
but what are you going to do you you i'm
going to write a concept
i'm going to write i know so i said this
i go i don't know who it belongs to and
i said i'm really just trying to find
out who in a fun way yeah that's the way
i'm coding it
and he he said no you're gonna put a
ransom note in a stranger's mailbox
they're gonna read it and if they call
the cops you opened their mail you wrote
them a ransom note because the last one
i scanned
and i cause i only had the girl's email
address so i cut the note and then
scanned that note and sent a scan so
like i guess it wasn't like i went into
their mailbox and left a ransom note you
know but he's he is he is positive that
it's not going to go down a good path
for me if i do what is he i mean he
thinks the law enforcement has the
resources this is what i'm saying
suspended on that this is what i'm
saying i was like let's say let's say
she calls the police and the police come
and i go i'm sorry i was like i i it had
nothing nothing on it i opened it i
didn't know who i just figured i have a
little phone with it i had no one it
didn't even get to this point it
wouldn't
he's certain it would dude he's so
afraid have you have you ever had a bike
stolen or something like that and go to
the police to try and report it yeah
they're like essentially like
i understand that's what happened
because they're like yeah take care of
you take care brush your hair right but
this apparently it's because of i opened
the mail he's saying but i'm telling you
the mail has no name on it and i would
never know where it was could have been
for you and so well that's what i said
to him too that's what i go
well i'm just lucky that i looked at it
because i was like well what is this i
was looking for a label from the company
and i was like and i saw that but i said
what if i just opened it by accident
that wouldn't matter he goes here but
you just said it on the podcast now so
now you he's a [ __ ] madman it makes
no sense what he's saying yeah so you
would say to cut another ransom note
drop it in this person's mailbox do you
know whose mailbox it would be
uh
no i don't know the person then i don't
know what the name and i don't know who
it belongs to you have a mailbox i have
that
i have an address
ish okay do it what's gonna happen yeah
i think i think you'd do it but sign it
joe derosa
yeah that [ __ ] is on the list
somewhere you know that yeah
i think he's panicking i i that sounds
like well i guess the cyberlogic that
comes from staring at a pit
for best friend i guess i like the
ransom note last time was for an
unmarked duffel full of honey skippy
peanut butter so it was like a joke so i
gotta ask for something that they're not
gonna be like this is an atrocity i'm
scared like this is
uh you gotta go for it what does he know
maybe we should maybe we should
source from our listeners
what i should demand in the uh make it
all everybody accomplishes that'd be
great source what i should ask for in
the ransom note they can't arrest you
all
they cannot arrest us no but if they
were going to rest good luck trying yeah
you don't even take us alive
that's
insane i'm
to add on to the bit on stage and he's
like just walk down the street and write
stuff about life for a bit he's like
don't commit a crime and and search for
a bit this way and i'm like but why
first of all i love his approach to
comedy just walk down the street and
write he's like do what everyone else
does he goes walk down the street and
write about it what let me say that yeah
hey well he said the freezer aisle yeah
you guys walk down the super freezer
aisle and then you observe it and write
about it
is that really all it takes to be a
stand-up comic just to just walk down
the road it's an island's background
the joe derosa school of comedy well
it's certainly how you get it to owning
a sandwich shop i guess
we have this new thing now because
there was a joke we did we did a uh
taste buds like months ago and big j was
a guest and casey yeah
and it was his opening night
and
he we were we were there and we started
talking about the place and apparently
it's across the street from a school and
we started mocking him like oh you
really did a research you opened up a
bar across you from a school over there
and another school over there and then
we started joking like ah
you trying to get kids in here like you
know with the sandwiches you're trying
to get kids into the sandwiches and he
got so upset on the pod and he's like
guys do not put that out there i don't
want that to be the thing i don't want
to be a joke well i calmed down he was
really flustered because they had it
opening night was happening and he still
needed to do a lot of things and it was
running late and he was like that first
night of my new business jitters but he
exploded and he got so upset and the
more he got upset the more we were
leaning into it yeah he did the wrong
thing
stop the cameras
and he's like stop it i don't want this
and you had to cut out a bunch of it but
we left a little bit of a light-hearted
summon there was too funny so we left a
little bit of like just a couple of
quips of like yeah children are always
welcome down here just come to the back
to get your sandwich so now in the like
10 podcast since then it just i don't
know how it comes out we don't do it on
purpose but something comes up always we
always go children are always welcome
down to joey roses and we just die
laughing all the time and i made like a
lower third with like little kid
cartoons yeah
so now it's like any time we get a
chance if kids come up we're like
speaking of kids come on down to joey
roses oh that was [ __ ] hysterical
but i don't know where i was going i
don't know why i brought that up i think
you're going to prison
oh
oh yeah yeah yeah so yeah so he's got
that on his back seems like he's
concerned about things that wouldn't
concern me in a normal course of life
where are we at too much we're at like
uh 50. oh
wow
all right yeah uh anything anything you
want to
tell them oh i was gonna bring up this
dude oh you wanna you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna spill the beans i'm
not it's actually because i can't i have
to actually do oh no i have a coal in
one minute oh all right all right well
then no nothing to plug man let's not
get a plug you know the dates check out
the merch i'm at the beacon on may 14th
in new york city may 22nd los angeles
savile county comedy.com uh
thank you brian please love being here
see chris again soon this has been hey
babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey